I had a very interesting time at prom I
still happen to go with a guy to prom
but I also had a girlfriend at the time
we were closeted our family and our
friends didn't know we would never have
gone to prom with each other I wish more
than anything that I could go back and
redo my prom we here at BuzzFeed like so
many of you believe that everyone should
have the freedom to express who they are
and who they love especially when it
comes to celebrations like pong which
should include the LGBTQ community I do
go to my high school prom I didn't even
think it was a possibility to go with a
girl because I hadn't seen that as an
option and I didn't think that it would
ever be something safe that I could do
yeah my prom experience was really
straight um I went to a private
Christian high school that was very much
uniform and all kind of the same very
conservative it was very much a closeted
experience for me there weren't any
openly LGBT people I really went to wear
a suit or a tuxedo or some sort and my
mom said that if I was going to prom I
had to wear a dress and I said you know
what well I'm not gonna wear a dress in
because that's not who I am I made a
choice not to go to prom trying to show
my mom that this is Who I am if I did
wear a suit I do know that I still would
have been that is inclusive as you know
everyone else feels when they're at prom
I remember seeing like probably one or
two queer couples at my prom I remember
thinking that I was very scared about
drawing that kind of attention to myself
I felt like I wasn't ready I happen to
have gone with a girl even though I knew
that I was gay it was kind of something
that I was doing just to make other
people happy I've never been a big
person about dances but that's because I
never felt welcome in those spaces even
like super out queer people were not
going with same-sex partners
I do remember how I'm come from
my phone and how like not cute I thought
right and it's because I was wearing
this tux and I felt very like robotic I
look back on pictures and I like to cry
and I think that it has a lot to do with
the fact that I've come to realize and
accept that I'm trans and then I would
have much rather appreciated wearing a
dress and had my hair up and had a bunch
of makeup on had I seen other queer
students accepting themselves and being
comfortable with their partners and with
their identities it would have helped me
come to my realisation much sooner as
shown by the personal stories of even
just the people who work here
many schools continue to discourage and
even exclude LGBTQ students from their
own problems Crom represents the right
to experience an important and joyous
event and it should be without
discrimination I successfully went to
prom with my girlfriend at the time
everybody around us was super supportive
when I see young kids having problems
taking whoever they want it's so
heartbreaking for me because I think
that was a really defining moment in my
coming-out journey my high school prom
experience was extraordinary myself no
dropping at the time going to prom
together which was the first time in the
history of my high school that I had
ever been done so needless to say it was
a bit heavy before the prom starts we
all gather in her High School Auditorium
and you get a walk out on stage holding
the hand of your date and there were
questions about whether we would just go
directly to prom my answer to that was a
resounding [ __ ] now of course I'm
walking out holding her hand and I am so
grateful for that experience I know that
it helped shape exactly who I am today
when I was in high school I went to five
proms with five straight women and never
once did I see a same-sex couple there
when I think about the problems that
I've been to in the past and the
problems that still lie ahead I think
it's so important that we celebrate our
differences we're here to announce that
BuzzFeed is throwing queer prom
a night where people of all sexual
orientations and gender identities can
celebrate prom the way it should be
inclusive diverse fabulous
homo normativity fashion glamorous gay
pride everyone coming together being one
we wanted to be available to people who
need it most a group of people who
contact us will be flown out to Los
Angeles to attend the event and to star
in a special BuzzFeed video series
please follow the link below to learn
more information about our prom and how
to access other resources for LGBT youth
we hope that through this experience we
can shine a light on how prom should be
welcomed to everyone and that means
including people who are changing the
future for the better we're talking
about you now everybody dance
[Music]
Oh fine food food please leather daddy
were super queer unicorns dancing these
are not at the tip suits dresses
rainbows who the [ __ ] cares what you
want